it's in a way it's one of the biggest
questions that perhaps the biggest
question there is in science is is
does some kind of
Supernatural intelligence look
behind the universe is the universe a
planned
um
entity that that's a super
natural being conceived I mean that's a
profound scientific question if it's
true then we're then the entire universe
we're looking at is a very different
kind of Universe from one where there's
nothing behind it
um and so it's a very very deep
scientific question
um and I think the the answer is clear
there is none but I I don't write it off
as something trivial because I don't
write it off as a case where you can
just say
um
it's not interesting course is
interesting
um it's interesting scientist has got to
be interested in this suggestion that
the sort of universe we're studying is a
planned designed universe that's a very
very different kind of universe so it's
a very it's a very deep question it is a
very deep question because
I I sense and I'm not a scientist that
the more you discover about the world
the more you learn about the Beauties
the details the intricacies the way
things are interlocked together isn't
maybe a part of you that thinks
this can't have been an accident there
must be something else here
it's very very tempting to say yes
everything works so perfectly together
and the the for me as a biologist the
complexity of Life the the enormous
panoply of of plants and animals and
forests and birds and insects everything
working together no it's it's a huge
beautiful construction and
what for me what is absolutely marvelous
is that nevertheless there is a
perfectly decent explanation that it did
all come about without without planning
so one of the beauties of it is
precisely that we now can explain it
well well on our way to explaining it
without invoking any kind of
Supernatural intelligence and it is a
great Temptation because
um we are so used to the idea looking at
our own machines looking at things that
we've made like computers and cars and
planes and these are
clearly
the result of design deliberate design
deliberate construction and when you
look at something like a bird's Wing
compared with an airplane's Wing the
Temptation is huge to say oh they must
both be designed and it was the genius
of Darwin to break away from that and so
you actually know there is a proper
explanation there is a a materialistic
explanation for that
um and so so the flip side of of the of
the Temptation is that when you've
overcome the Temptation and worked out
that it is possible to explain it in
simple scientific advice I really mean
simple because the ideas yeah I did I
was like there's deeply simple idea and
yet
given enough time
the darwinian idea of natural selection
given enough time can build up to
prodigies of complexity and beauty
and the illusion of design and that's a
that's a measure of the genius of Darwin
to see that
thank you